look Joey I'm a drummer to top one guy
everything he knows what's going on with
those two
I've no idea no idea
well let's smoke and maybe get some some
clarity because the Wolfman thought the
other kid he left him the truck he wants
1800 I heard it yeah my friend he has
friends
I guess they stole all of his stuff like
they knew he'd get messed up I just
don't think he has a strong case but I
don't you know I don't think the other
guy is completely innocent because why
would he give his chalk to this dude the
kid was in San Diego he went on he got
up he gets what he deserves they gave
him a cosmic pill and pa1 and he woke up
with nothing that's what happens next
time you pay attention loading a truck
to werewolf you imagine the road range
those those werewolves have when they're
out driving
he's like didn't walk up loses sir for
sure but it sounds like the guy admits
that he's had the car so the law would
say that he owes for the car but the car
is not worth 1,800 1,800 bucks it's
giving 250 250 in the buckets he's got
another let him off play the drill
whatever we give him we definitely have
to crumple it up and throw it into his
bucket
[Music]
Oh